Film Courage: How do you keep an audience
guessing with plot twists and reveals?
Phillip G. Carroll, Jr., Writer/Director:
When I was working on THE HONEYMOON PHASE
had this mindset of the film, it’s like
the Hot Wheel car track where…maybe this
is because I grew up with Hot Wheel cars…where
on the track for the Hot Wheel cars there
is there’s like these little spinning motors
that will push the car further.
It goes down the hill, it reaches the bottom,
it reaches a part where naturally the gravity
would stop the car because it would run to
the end of the track, then there would be
a motor that would push it along further and
throughout the track there would be all of
these motors that eventually where it needed
to go next.
To me that’s kind of a good analogy for
a script where you have these key scenes in
the story which are your “motors” that
push the story further, so like the attention
grabbing moments because a lot of points of
your story are where your characters are doing
things that on a surface level maybe aren’t
the most entertaining things to watch but
are important to the story but you need these
motors to keep the audience guessing and keep
them engaged.
In HONEYMOON PHASE we would throughout the
story when I was outlining I would pick points
where I was like Ah…I think we need a motor
here and then come up with a twist or something
that made sense within the realm of the film
to keep the audience guessing.
You would do that by thinking about the characters
and where they are in that point of the story
and what their belief is in their present
world and then how do you flip that on its
head by making them question their own reality.
This is a psychological thriller so I guess
that is why some of that terminology is coming
into play there but the Hot Wheel track is
kind of how I view a story.
Film Courage: And so the loop [of the car
track], that would be toward then end?
Phil: That would be the big twists.
I think that would be a very Hollywood way
of thinking about it where a lot of blockbuster
films have their “set-piece” moments,
they would be the moments or the big reveals
and then in-between you have the scenes that
are important to the story but maybe aren’t
your trailer moments or the things that are
going to leave you like with your jaw dropped
because you find out that this person is cheating
on this person or that person is the bad one
(the gear moments).
Film Courage: Are there any films that you
love which are from the arthouse genre that
are not Hollywood movies?
Which were really powerful, the way characters
played against one another?
Phil: I’m trying to think.
Most of the films that I grew up with were
Hollywood films and independent films like
as I matured as a film goer I start appreciating
more independent film as well.
Arthouse film was nothing that I was able
to I guess connect with as a viewer.
And that is not to say that I don’t respect
it as an art form.
I think it’s beautiful and there is so much
to be said in arthouse movies, it’s just
as a viewer I could never connect with it.
It’s more of a genre that I respect but
maybe don’t necessarily connect with.